[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHET HAASE: Wow,
what tepid applause.
Thank you.
CHRIS CRAIK: Hey, my
name is Chris Craik.
I work on Android UI Toolkiit.
CHET HAASE: And I'm Chet Haas.
I also work on the
Android UI Toolkit team.
And today, why don't we
talk about performance?
It's been a while since
we've had a performance talk.
So we thought we
should do it again
because we like talking
about performance.
For this year's
performance talk,
we wanted to make it a
bit more use-case driven,
tell you a bit about how
rendering works, some
of the changes
that we made, some
of the improvements
around performance,
but also go through some steps
of how you would actually
find out what jank is, and how
to fix it in your applications.
So let's do that.
UI performance,
hey, there you go.
So we talk about
frames per second, FPS.
It's a really good metric.
It's a good way for
understanding what's
going on in your application.
But it's actually better to
think about the duration,
right?
So it's not how many frames
per second you can hit.
Honestly, the display is
hitting 60 frames a second
all the time.
And then you need to sort
of hit the same number
of frames for your
application in each second.
But it's really better to
think about the duration
that each frame is taking.
How long is that frame
taking to actually draw?
Because you're not going
to fit within that window
if you're taking
too long to fit.
So if you want to fix the
jank in your application,
if you want to fix
the stutters, if when
you're flinging and
scrolling that list,
there's skipped
frames in the middle,
and the user is seeing
this janky behavior,
fixing that means fixing
the frames that are simply
taking too long.
So also, it's good to
think about consistency.
It's great if you
can have 60 frames
per second most of the time.
But then occasionally, if
you're dropping several frames
in a row, that's not good.
What you really want
is consistent behavior.
So chasing jank is all about
finding the places where you're
dropping those and
making sure that you're
fixing the bottlenecks that
are contributing to those.
So let's talk about time.
Let's take a look at time
going forward, from the left,
to the right--
sorry, from the
left to the right--
and take a look at what's
happening in the UI space.
So if you think about these
vertical refresh syncs,
on every 16 and
2/3 milliseconds,
typically, on a typical display,
we're getting a Vsync request,
right?
So this is the hardware
sort of posting the frame
to the screen.
That is when the
user sees something.
So divide that by 60 second,
divided by 60, 16 2/3.
I can go over the math
later if you need me to.
Then if you map frames onto
that, each of these frames,
this is sort of
these gray boxes are
what your application is
doing in order to post
that information to the screen.
So ideally, all
of the stuff that
needs to happen for that frame
would be within that 16 and 2/3
milliseconds.
I need to stop saying that.
I'm going to say 16 milliseconds
and you can interpret it
however you want.
So the beautiful icon that
I hand-drew myself down
to the bottom of the screen,
that's the user seeing things.
So on each of those
vertical syncs,
they are seeing whatever
the hardware buffer
is posting to the screen.
So they're going to see
it there, there, there.
But if there's a
problem when you're
rendering, if one of your
frames takes too long,
then the user is not
going to see that.
They're going to see
exactly what they
saw in the previous
frame, because you
took too long in
your application,
and you skipped a frame.
So that's jank.
That's the stutter that we
need to try to analyze and fix.
So let's take a little
step back and say, OK,
how does rendering actually
happen in the UI toolkit?
Well, there's the app
perspective, so what's
going on in your
application, and then we'll
take a look at what the
framework is actually
doing on your behalf.
So here's some simple code.
I keep looking back at, OK,
so you can see on the screen
back here.
Here's some simple code.
We have this color.
Things are light gray right now.
And when the user clicks in
the middle of this custom view,
we're going to change the color.
We're going to tell
the view that it needs
to invalidate
itself, and then it's
going redraw in the new color.
So, user clicks on
the screen, that
sends an event into
the onclick method,
we're going to
change things around,
then we're going to invalidate.
And then invalidate is going to
cause a later call to onDraw.
It's not a serial thing.
It doesn't directly call onDraw.
But it tells the system, hey,
things need to be redrawn.
And then a later call will
filter into the onDraw method.
And then the onDraw will
draw into the canvas,
and that will eventually
be posted to the screen
through all the operations
that the UI toolkit is
doing on your behalf.
So from the platform
perspective, what's going on
is several things in a row.
First of all, on
any given frame,
when we get that Vsync
request, we process input.
So if the user is clicked,
if the user is scrolling
or flinging, that's where
we get that information
and do something based on it.
If there's animation,
if they have
let go of that scrolling list,
and it's now flinging and just
posting events so that it
gets updated as the list
moves in space, or as views
move around on the screen,
we process those
animation events.
We change the properties.
That causes invalidation
so that things
can get redrawn appropriately.
Then, if necessary,
we do layout.
So if something changed
in your application that
changes things,
size or location,
that's when we
measure and lay out
the things that need to
be changed, again, causing
invalidation and redraws.
And then we actually do
what we call record draw.
So this is what we were
seeing on the previous slide,
in the onDraw method.
This is where you
turn whatever you
want to do into drawing
operations that we then receive
and store internally.
So you're going to say, well,
canvas, draw this new color.
So you're recording
the commands that
should happen in order
for us to then draw
the right thing under the hood.
And then finally, render.
And that's our stage in this.
So you do everything in
the first four steps,
in your codes, or for standard
views, we're doing it.
And then we handle
the rendering.
And that's basically
the transformation
of those recorded draw
calls into whatever we
need to do at the bottom layer.
I'll give you a hint.
We turn it into OpenGL
or GPU commands,
that we then send to the GPU.
So if we look at that beautiful,
brilliant colors, which we're
going to use in some
upcoming diagrams,
we have these five
stages, right?
So in any particular frame,
the boring gray box there,
it's actually broken down
into those different stages.
In our previous example, in
that simple application code,
we didn't have all of
the stages because there
was no layout required.
All we were doing
was changing a color.
So we had the input
of the onclick,
and then we had the record
draw of the canvas operation
to draw in the new
color, and then
the rendering operation
that resulted from that.
In a typical-- yeah, just
like it says on the slide.
In a typical application,
more general frame,
then you're going to have
all of the steps in there.
So we may process some
input and some animation
and some layout and
record and then render.
And all of these things are
happening in a sequence.
So this is the
order of operations.
In reality, we actually
have two threads kicking in
as a lollipop, where we came
out with a render thread
technology, which we've talked
about before, where we process
all of the application
space stuff going on,
those first four steps
in the application space,
or on the UI thread.
And then we have this separate
thread that's actually
handling the rendering.
They still happen in
series, in sequence,
because the render
thread doesn't know what
to render until you tell it.
But the render thread can also
do other stuff asynchronously
from the UI thread.
So we can send over some
of the atomic animations
that it can process
in the meantime.
But in general, you do all
this stuff on the UI thread.
And then we sync that
information to the render
thread, and then render thread
on that separate thread,
will handle talking to the GPU.
So in a well-behaved
application, in a typical,
let's say this is a scrolling
or a flinging situation,
and things are well-behaved
in the application,
and you draw relatively quickly,
this is what things look like.
Again, the beautiful
eye icon at the bottom,
the user sees the frames
happen, bam, bam, bam, bam,
everything's happening within
the 16 millisecond barrier.
But, in a typical janky
situation, all of a sudden,
something took longer.
So here, we see that the input
command took a lot longer.
So maybe when the user clicks,
some expensive operation
was performed.
Somebody made a
web service call.
Or more typically, you
created or you bound a view.
You did some expensive
operation that
caused us to do a lot of work,
pushed out the length of time
that you're spending doing
all of that recording of draw
operations.
And then the rendering
operation necessarily slipped
into the next
frame, and the user
missed seeing that input because
it didn't hit the barrier.
So that's the jank, again,
that we want to fix.
CHRIS CRAIK: All
right, so let's move
over to talking
about what do you do?
You have problems
in the application.
You see now, as Chet has
described, what can happen
when the frame takes too long.
Let's talk about
the process that we
called de-janking, stepping
through your application,
and finding and
fixing these problems.
So the first step in
de-janking your application
is to run a release-ish build.
And so, what I mean
by that is, make
sure that you're running
with debugging off.
If you're running
with debugging on,
arc has to add in a
bunch of different checks
and verification steps that
can add a little bit of time
and skew your
results a little bit.
So we recommend overriding
that, or testing
an actual release build.
So the second step is to
inspect your app visually.
As you're scrolling
through lists,
if you see any jank occurring,
just visually detecting,
if you see an
animation, definitely
start with the most key,
important parts of your app.
Lots of you guys have a
primary scrolling list,
great place to start.
If you happen to be one
of the kind of people that
can't see jank, if you just see,
oh, well, it looks fine to me,
you can turn on
profile GPU rendering,
and that gives you
all of these bars
at the bottom,
which will tell you
when you pass that
particular threshold
and give you a little hint as
to what might be happening,
based upon the color.
And there's some documentation
about that online.
But the real next step, after
that, you've seen some jank,
you see, oh yes, when
these items come on screen,
or the first time that I load
this particular part of the UI,
you figure out what
the interaction is,
and you say, OK,
what do I do next?
Well, the next step
is generally Systrace.
Systrace is a tool
that exists in the SDK,
in the platform tools directory.
You can also get
it off of GitHub
if you want the absolute
freshest version.
And so from here, we're going
to do a very quick live look
through what a Systrace
actually looks like.
So this is what you might
see when you pull up
a Systrace for the first time.
So in this particular
example, I was
scrolling through a
RecyclerView in my app.
And I saw oh, there's
some janky frames.
I can see some
visual stuttering.
And so I captured a Systrace
over the duration of that time.
And now I pull up a Systrace.
And oh my goodness, there is
a lot of information here.
There is a lot of noise.
It is really hard to see,
what should I be looking at?
So first and foremost,
what you can do
is you can look
here on the left.
You can see, OK,
well, there is kernel,
there is potentially
other processes.
You know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to ignore
everybody else for now,
and I'm going to scroll
down until the top process,
the only thing that
I can see right now
is my package, Android.janktown.
And in fact, you can even
go further than that.
You can look on the left here.
This tells you, in
fact, individual threads
that we care about.
And as Chet was
talking about, there
are two threads
that matter here.
There's the UI thread of my
app and the render thread.
So I'm going to
scroll down further,
until all that I can see, at
the very top of the screen,
is mostly that.
And so from a very high
level, even just looking
at this trace, without
knowing much about it,
I can say, OK, the time in this
trace goes from left to right.
On the leftmost we
have zero seconds
going all the way further.
And if you can't see
the specific details,
don't worry about it.
We'll go into some
zoomed-in screenshots later.
But even from this
very high-level view,
I can say, oh, well I got a
lot of tiny little slivers
here, these little pulses.
These are frames.
OK, great.
Most of that looks
incredibly consistent,
looks really
smooth, and it looks
to be repeating regularly.
However, there are some
big visual standouts here.
And this is very
often what de-janking
is, is looking for these
particular standout frames
and investigating.
So if I zoom in
here, I can start
looking at exactly what's
going wrong in these frames,
and I can start clicking
around, figuring out
exactly what the problem is.
And just so that
you can see that,
we're going to switch back
to slides and show you
the screenshots in particular.
So this is one of the
simple frames, zoomed
in pretty significantly,
that we saw earlier
as those very frequent
and very regular pulses.
Now these were very nice.
They looked like tiny
little slivers before.
But let's go ahead and look at
them to see what a baseline is.
So first of all, one of the
tricky things about Systrace
is, there's a lot of data here.
There's a lot of
things to click on.
But one of the nice features
is that most of these UI thread
components, click
on it, Systrace
will do its best to try
and explain it to you.
So if you click on this
particular type of the UI
thread, which means this is
the top most traced section.
This is the biggest chunk that
represents the UI thread work.
If you click on that, at the
bottom of the Systrace UI,
it'll say, oh, OK, well this
is what Choreographer is.
And in fact, here it'll even
link you to the documentation
where it describes on
d.android.com how Choreographer
works.
Similarly, if I want to
look down at draw frame,
that's the render thread
component of the frame.
And if I click on it, I
get a similar explanation.
There's lots of this
for all sorts of tracing
throughout Systrace,
especially on the UI and render
thread, where you might
be most interested.
OK, so now that we know
we can click on things,
we can get a little bit
more information that way,
let's go through exactly what
does this frame look like?
What's it doing?
So, the very first thing we see
here is an animation call back.
If you click on this,
it'll say animation.
Or if you zoom in,
you can see that.
And I'm just going to go
through these that way.
So this is animation
exactly as Chet
was talking about it before.
And if we saw before, we
had a whole lot of frames.
And I told you it
was a RecyclerView.
So there's one very common
reason for a RecyclerView
to be animating,
and that's flinging.
The flinging animation itself,
executes RecyclerView's actual
translate and inflate work as
part of an animation callback.
And then the other
stage that Chet talked
about before is record draw.
Well, this makes sense as
well, because RecyclerView view
is invalidating, sliding
things around, and drawing.
OK, we kind of get some
context for what it's doing.
And in fact, if you
click on this part
of the animation, which
is inside animation,
this is RecyclerView scroll.
So RecyclerView
scroll is actually
going really, really fast here.
And that's because RecyclerView
is doing very minimal work.
In fact, if we look at the
amount of time taken by this UI
frame, it's 1.25 milliseconds.
That's great.
The whole frame finishes
in less than six.
This is a great frame,
congratulations.
Now we look at a little
bit slower of a frame.
Now this one's
actually not terrible,
but let's look at how it
differs from the previous one.
So first of all, we notice that
there's a measure pass in here.
So something in the
hierarchy requested layout
and got remeasured.
OK, good to know.
Then another thing down
here, we see upload bitmap.
So the first time that the
RenderThread sees a bitmap
and needs to display it, it
will be uploaded to the GPU,
uploaded to OpenGL so that the
GPU can draw it really fast.
Now that first upload
is a little expensive,
and we'll talk about
that a bit more later.
But really, if we look at
it, well, the UI thread
takes four milliseconds,
the entire frame
finishes in less than 13.
This is not a problem frame.
This is fine.
But now let's look at
the really bad ones.
These were the ones that
we saw from very far away.
OK, something is
definitely going on here.
But if you're new,
like, what's going on?
How do I figure out
what's going on?
So actually, if you click
on this part that says,
RV CreateView, it'll
describe to you
that this is basically
your adapter's callback
for onCreateViewHolder.
This means that RecyclerView
needs a new view,
and it's creating it.
And in fact, if you look
directly below that,
well, a lot of the reason,
a lot of the time that
takes up this
CreateView portion,
is that it's inflating.
And inflating, especially
with the complex items
in my RecyclerView,
can take a while.
Well, that's unfortunate.
The next part here,
onBindViewHolder, that
takes about a
millisecond and a half.
Not great, but OK,
well what can I do?
You know, this UI thread frame
took about 20 milliseconds
on the UI thread and
totaled to be about 27.4.
Not great.
We are definitely going
to jank that frame.
So this is actually,
this process
is one that you might
go through yourself.
But in this particular
case, we realize,
well this is something
that we can help you out
with in support lib.
And this is a feature
that we worked in
for exactly that purpose.
So let's go back and
talk a little bit
about what RecyclerView does.
So RecyclerView is the
primary support lib component
for displaying a dynamic
list of content that
needs to show views
dynamically, that needs
to scroll infinitely,
potentially, or display
more content than what is
attached to the view hierarchy.
So what do I mean?
Well, I mean, if you have
these four items partially
visible in your RecyclerView,
you start scrolling,
and all the RecyclerView needs
to do is handle these four
particular items.
In fact, all that it has to do
is offset them very slightly.
And that's the amount
of work that we see.
And in fact, if you
remember, the very first RV
scroll that we
highlighted, it was tiny.
It was trivial because
RecyclerView did very little.
But once we get to the edge
of this particular list, well,
what happens?
Now we suddenly
might see some jank
because this is a frame in which
something interesting happens.
For the first time, this
list has five items in it.
That means it can't get an item
to be recycled from previously.
That means this message
icon had to be inflated.
Well, so that's the old way
of RecyclerView working.
So let's go back to a sort
of simplified version of what
we saw in the Systrace.
Let's say, again, that
this happened during fling.
We have two frames
that look totally fine.
They have short UI
thread durations
and very reasonable
RenderThread durations
finished before the deadline.
But then suddenly, you hit
a big chunk of animation.
And as we know, in
this particular case,
that's because RecyclerView
is doing it's create and bind
work.
So we see something
funny here, though.
With RenderThread
working as it does,
the UI thread is totally idle
for the 10 or so milliseconds
in advance of this
new frame coming on.
Well, it's not hard to
predict that the fling is
going to continue.
I mean, that's kind
of what animations do.
And this create
work, it actually
could have fit right there.
So this is exactly what we
do in RecyclerView Prefetch.
We started looking
ahead to new items that
are about to come on
screen and basically
stealing work from them.
Realizing, oh no, that's
going to do a lot of work.
Let me steal a
little bit of that.
Let me go ahead and
do that inflation
early so that we don't
have to do that on demand.
And this is what it
looks like in practice.
So this is a Systrace
from the exact same app.
All that I did was
update the support
lib to get this feature.
And suddenly, we get an RV
Prefetch event in Systrace.
Again, click on it, it
explains the Prefetch feature,
what it does.
And we see, wow, that's 13 1/2
milliseconds that we pulled out
of the next frame.
We saved a huge amount
of time by work stealing.
And this is one great
example of something
that the support lib has done,
but it's absolutely the process
that you can go
through for looking
for problems in your own app.
Support lib can't solve
every problem this way.
But look, let's talk about
Prefetch a little bit more.
So there are some caveats.
So what happens if the
item isn't actually needed?
What happens if we
Prefetch an item,
and suddenly, just
before that item is
about to come on screen, the
user decides to tap the screen,
stop the fling?
If the fling is stopped, if you
don't end up needing the item,
or if something else
comes in, some last minute
arrival of new data, you might
have done the work incorrectly.
And really, that's fine.
99.9% of the time,
Prefetch is going
to make the right
decision, and you
might waste a little bit of
work in that particular case.
What if there's no
RenderThread though?
If there's no
RenderThread, we just
don't try and Prefetch,
to begin with right now.
So because RenderThread is on
the vast majority of devices,
you get this on most
devices for free,
by just using a recent
version of the support lib.
But on older devices,
this feature doesn't work.
So availability,
this was actually
introduced a while ago,
with support lib v.25.
But it's been getting better,
including with the most
recent beta of 26.
This feature is built into
default layout manager,
so if you just use a
RecyclerView, horizontal,
vertical, whatever, with linear,
or staggered, or grid layout,
you just get this for free.
This is just from updating
to the newer support lib.
However, if you have a
custom layout manager,
if you wanted to do
something completely custom,
or if you wanted to subclass one
of them in an interesting way,
just be aware that you
may need to override
this particular method, collect
adjacent Prefetch positions.
And this is how you, in
your custom layout manager,
can get the exact same behavior.
And you can look at
the implementations
of the other ones.
And you can read more about
this in Chet's wonderful post
about RecyclerView
Prefetch on medium.
But let's step back a little
bit and talk about, well,
what happens to jank?
Well, we saw in
this particular case
that RecyclerView having bursty
workloads could cause jank.
But let's talk about sort
of, stepping back, what
has historically been the
problems for Android and jank?
So one of the oldest ones
that we've thought about
is garbage collection.
Garbage collection historically
had been a significant problem
on Android.
But this has been
something that the platform
has been improving steadily.
So GC for alloc was essentially
fixed in L with ART.
I've looked at
hundreds of traces,
I haven't seen a blocking GC
on any but the most egregiously
allocating apps.
GC is not a huge problem.
But even still, the
runtime keeps improving.
Runtime keeps
getting better at GC,
lowering the overhead
of allocation.
OS Thread scheduling, so this is
a particularly interesting one,
where on older
versions of the kernel,
and on older versions
of Android, sometimes
the platform will just make
a bad decision about when
to schedule your application.
This has been improving
greatly, especially in N/O,
but it is unfortunately,
kernel specific.
So that means that
it's not guaranteed
to be in every N or O device.
But definitely look
for newer devices,
if you're looking specifically
into thread scheduling,
if you're trying to make sure
that your work is running
exactly when you want it to.
Rendering is an interesting one.
I work a whole lot on rendering.
Rendering, specifically,
one of the things
that I remember Chet and
Ramon talking about years ago,
has been View Alpha.
Let's see, there's has
overlapping rendering,
there's set layer
type hardware, there's
some other callbacks somewhere,
that I need to remember.
Well, we tried to improve that.
So we started adding
Auto-Hardware layer M,
get that for free, and M+, you
can still use Hardware Layer
to avoid that problem.
But we've gotten even
further improvements in N,
improving the worst case.
Bitmap uploads are
another one that I
talked about earlier
that can cause
a significant amount of delay
in first displaying your bitmap.
But we added a new feature
in N, prepareToDraw
on bitmaps, that would
allow bitmap loading
libraries to asynchronously
start that work early,
and that's starting
to be adopted by them.
View Recycling, just
as I said before,
was another common
cause that basically
support lib has significantly
improved for you.
So added in 25, more
improvements to come there.
And you can go back and watch
the recording of the ART
session from this I/O if
you want to learn more
about what ART has been doing.
But I wanted to go
through all of those
because I think
that that tells you
a lot about how the platform
has been improving, and trying
to get to the point where
the only sources of jank
in your application are
ones that you can solve.
So let's talk a little bit about
some of the sources of jank
that might happen in
an application, that
might happen because
of something that's
going wrong inside your app.
And there are a lot of them.
But let's just go
really quickly.
So issues in
RecyclerView, we talked
about issues with RecyclerView
needing to inflate,
doing that work at
the last minute,
lazily, possibly causing
10 milliseconds or more
of work in a single frame.
But there's a lot of other
subtle issues in RecylcerView
that can cause
unnecessary inflation.
And talk a little
bit more about that.
So bitmap painting
on the UI thread,
one of the most common
reasons for your draw callback
to be very long,
is because you're
trying to cache some work,
cache some content in a bitmap.
But unfortunately, drawing
to a software bitmap
can take a lot of time,
especially if it's anywhere
near screen size.
Canvas calls, there are a few
canvas calls, namely draw path
if you're mutating
your path frequently,
save layer, that can
be somewhat expensive.
And we've actually
gone out of our way
to document some of these.
And I'll mention this coming up.
But let's go quickly
to an example of Binder
because this has been one of
the favorite investigations
of the Android performance
team in the past release
has been looking and fixing
binding Binder problems.
So Binder is the IPC
mechanism on Android.
If you want to talk
to Window Manager,
or if the view
hierarchy thinks you
want to talk to
Window Manager, you're
probably going through Binder.
If you're talking to another
person's content provider,
if you're talking
to surface flinger,
across IPC, you're
probably going through Binder.
And Binder has tracing.
Now unfortunately, IPC
is often very expensive.
And truth be told, it can be
really easy to accidentally add
to your application.
Here's a particular
screenshot of Systrace
that has a lot of Binder
transactions going on
during RecyclerView scroll.
If you look at it, Binder,
Binder, oh my goodness,
and then they're just running
another callback on the UI
thread, running lots of Binder.
All of these are
pretty significant.
It's a 21 millisecond frame.
It's not doing any
inflation, it's
not doing anything that should
absolutely take that long.
It's just Binder
overheads doing work
that they really shouldn't
be doing on the UI thread.
So tracing Binder
can help a whole lot,
and that's on by default in the
newest versions of Systrace.
But to summarize,
there's a lot of reasons.
And we've documented
a whole lot of them.
If you go to
d.android.com/vitals,
we have a lot of the material
in this presentation,
a lot of those samples that I
went to in more depth with code
examples, so on and so
forth, on this web site.
And so now I'm going
to pass it back
to Chet who's going to talk
about maintaining performance
in your app.
CHET HAASE: I should
point out, too,
that the document that
Chris pointed to is new.
It was just posted.
CHRIS CRAIK: Yeah,
just Wednesday.
CHET HAASE: So if you think the
performance docs on the site,
you might want to
check it out anyway.
Much more detailed,
in-depth info.
And the documentation
team was working
really closely with the
engineers like Chris
and other teams to get
the information that
was really accurate and deep to
help you with this de-janking.
So let's talk about how
you can find, and fix,
and actually maintain
your own app performance.
It boils down to sort of
four steps, you can think of.
One is that you can gather user
statistics, so actually figure
out where the problems are.
You can add your own tracing.
It's important to note, when
we're looking at all Systrace
stuff that Chris was showing,
that's not a sampling profiler.
We're not seeing
per method calls.
That's not all the stuff that's
going on in your application.
Those are specific traces
that we have instrumented
the framework and the
platform code with,
so the only thing you're
going to see in Systrace
are the traces that we've
actually added to the platform.
Because if we add
a ton of traces,
then it's going to slow
down the application.
So we add it in the places
where it really makes sense.
So you can actually add
your own tracing stuff.
We'll show you how to do that.
You can add jank tests.
So maybe you actually
need continuous tests
so that you can tell when
you implement a change,
and you have a new build
of your application,
and your performance goes down.
Wouldn't that be nice if you
knew that instead of depending
on lower ratings on Play
Store because your users
are the first ones to see that?
Maybe you could actually
have continuous tests
that can catch that for you.
And then finally, use the tools.
He went in-depth on
Systrace, but it's worth
thinking about some
other ones that
should be a part of your normal
toolbox when you're developing.
So one of the things
I should point out
in looking at the
user stats is this
is a screenshot of a
dashboard that is now--
it's actually, it's sort of
a theoretical screenshot.
We don't actually give gray
boxes, that would mean nothing.
So this is from a talk that
the Play team gave on Wednesday
and talked about the
different metrics
that they can provide
on the Dashboard now.
So there are metrics that are
being calculated and stored
on the device, that, depending
on whether the user opts
into it, may be
uploaded and then it
can be information on your
Dashboard for your application.
So you can see what
people are actually
seeing in the real world,
including jank stats.
So how many of your
frames are coming in,
that's sort of a histogram
of these duration buckets.
So how many frames are
coming in at each level
of that histogram.
So you can get an idea, not
just for how your application is
doing in general, but also
if you just updated it,
and things got worse,
wouldn't that be nice to know?
That information that's
being aggregated and shown
in the Play Dashboard is
actually coming from internals
that we have in
the platform that
were injected in the N release,
where we have this thing called
frame metrics.
And we have an API
around that as well.
And we compile this thing
at a very low level.
But you can listen in on that.
You can implement this
OnFrameMetricsAvailableListener.
And get the per frame
callback data, that says, OK,
here's what the
duration was for each
of these individual things.
And if you think
about, if you've
done the GPU profile, or
the on screen profiler,
we saw the screenshot earlier,
all of that information
is exactly the
durations that you get
from the FrameMetricsListener.
How long did input take?
How long did animation take?
How long was the total
duration of the frame?
So you can get all
of that information,
aggregate it yourself,
and then upload
and analyze to your
heart's content.
We simplified that a little
bit in v26 of the support lib.
So the beta release should
have those bits now.
So instead of listening per
frame and getting the durations
and then needing
to aggregate them,
we aggregate them
for you so you can
get this SparseIntArray of
duration buckets, basically
a histogram.
And then again, you can
compile, aggregate this stuff,
on the device and then
upload it to whatever
server you choose
to analyze offline.
So the Play Store Dashboard
does that for you,
for your overall application.
But if you want to
instrument particular flows
in your application
that are really
sensitive or important
for you to get right,
then you can choose to do that
with the frame metric stuff.
Custom tracing-- so as I
said, all of the traces
that we saw in the Systrace
example that Chris was showing
were the standard traces
that we have on the platform.
But you have the ability
to add your own traces
in your application.
So you should think about doing
this for some of the things
that you think might be more
expensive, where you know
you're triggering
layouts, or whatever
you want to do it for--
for when you're binding
views or creating
things that may be
expensive, maybe you
want to add a trace
there, and sort of
see what that time
is going to be,
and what it looks
like in Systrace.
It's important to know that
the more you instrument,
the more time you're
going to spend actually
outputting the
instrumentation information.
That's why we don't have
per method instrumentation.
On one hand, you don't want too
much information in Systrace,
because then the important
information gets lost.
But also, you don't
want to actually skew
your times by the
instrumentation calls
that you're actually making.
So same thing is true
for your application.
So you should think
about, if it's
going to take greater
than a half a millisecond,
then the overhead of
the instrumentation
is going to be in the noise.
But if it's much
faster than that,
you probably don't want
to do that, at least not
on any permanent basis.
And performance
tests, it's always
good to have tests anyway.
Wouldn't it be nice
if you actually
knew when you were triggering
a performance problem?
This is especially true
for big apps and big teams.
So if you have many
developers chucking code
into a common code
base, it's good to have
an automated way of detecting
when problems come in.
If they're not-- if you have
developers chucking code
in that are not as familiar
with your architecture
or your practices,
then you want to be
able to detect that
earlier, instead
of catching at the user level.
And you want to,
in particular, have
tests around the
areas of your UI
that are more important, right?
So if there's a common
feed, some common list
view, RecylerView
situation that people
are going to be going into
all the time, if that's
where everybody lands, well,
create some performance
tests around that, and make
sure that that code stays tight.
You can gather the
data on the user sides,
on the device side,
and the app side,
and FrameMetricsAggregator.
Or you can also do
it on the host side.
So you can run these command
line tools, dumpsys gfxinfo,
that will get all
of that information.
Gfxinfo, again,
this is the same--
it's a different view
into exactly the same kind
of duration data that I was
talking about earlier that you
see in GPU profiling,
that you see
in FrameMetrics aggregation.
And in particular,
you want to watch
what's going on with the
different percentiles
of your app.
If you skip a frame
occasionally, no big deal.
If occasionally you have a
700 millisecond frame drop,
that's probably a big deal.
Or if you have
10% of your frames
that are actually missing their
boundaries, that's a big deal.
So just pay attention to,
A, what your app is doing,
and know what the
performance is like,
and try to get that
performance as good as you can.
But also, pay attention to
what's changing over time.
As you update that
app, make sure
that you're not losing
performance as you do it.
And then finally, use the tools.
So we talked about Profile
GPU Rendering, something
you can enable in
developer options
very easily, just sort of
see where things are going,
what's going on
in the device when
you fling your RecyclerView
or whatever your common UI
case is.
That green line is important.
If you're going
above the green line,
you missed the 16
millisecond boundary.
And you janked a frame.
This one looks like a
particularly janky frame.
I don't think they're
making any frame there.
So at least they're consistent.
They've got that going for them.
So you can do that
on the device.
This is more at the
debugger and developer
level, just sort of see
where things are at.
Again, it's using
the same information
that we compile at
the lowest level,
and just putting it on the
screen for ease of use.
Android Studio just came out
with some new profiling tools
in their latest release.
They were talking about that in
some of their talks this week.
So you can check those out
in the recordings on YouTube.
In particular,
for this audience,
the CPU monitor will
give you information
about what's actually going on
in all of these method calls.
It gives you a good
idea in general
about where the performance
is going in your app,
and also the GPU
monitor, which is, again,
another view into how fast
you're rendering this stuff,
and whether you're hitting
the 16 millisecond boundary.
CHRIS CRAIK: Yeah, in
fact, I want to say,
if you're ever familiar
with the previous tools that
used to be part of the SDK,
the Trace View, that was built
into monitor, this
does the same thing,
but with a far better
UI, far more usable,
and actually, far more
correct data as well.
So far, far more advisable.
CHET HAASE: So the way I
view the different tools.
So we saw the deep
dive in Systrace.
And especially when you first
see Systrace, you're like,
I never want to see
that tool again.
There's just so much
information there,
and you're not quite sure what
to do with the information.
That is the tool that has
all of the information,
it just takes a little
bit of getting used to
in using it to see how it
works and how you can divine
the information you need and
add the custom traces that you
want.
I think an easier way
to get into it, is
you can dip in slowly by using
the much easier to use, higher
level view of what's going on
with the Android Studio Tools.
And then if there's a
particular source of jank
that you're trying
to trace, know
that Systrace is a
fine grain tool that's
going to help you trace
that at a much deeper level
system-wide.
And finally, not on
topic, but for this
crowd that's interested
in performance,
you may want to try out
a developer option that
will enable this
alternative render, that's
not on by default.
But you can see
how your application
behaves with this,
for possible future
possibilities.
So it's the Skia Renderer, you
can go into developer options,
and enable that,
and just make sure
that there's not an issue there.
If there is, it'd be
lovely to hear about it.
That's why we're
mentioning it today.
There are some resources
that we mentioned.
I won't bring them up again.
Again, check out the vitals
page on d.android.com.
In particular, they have a jank
section called Slow Rendering.
And there are some
important I/O sessions
to check out on YouTube.
They are probably
posted already.
Tim Murray gave a great overview
about Systrace and system
performance in general.
So Android
Performance-- Overview.
The ART Talk talked about
performance and memory
improvements.
They did some
pretty amazing stuff
on both the runtime side,
runtime improvements,
as well as the GC side.
So now they have concurrent
garbage collection.
There's almost no
pauses anymore,
until they need to take
a full GC eventually.
And they can compact
in the foreground.
You get a minimal
sized heap, you
get much faster allocations,
as well as collections.
So the details for all of that
stuff are in the ART talk.
And then finally, there's a
talk by the Play folks, called
"No One Likes Crashing Or
Janky Apps," which is true.
And that's where they talked
about the Dashboard and some
of the other
facilities that they're
providing for developers.
And that is the talk.
CHRIS CRAIK: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]